i've seen so many skunks lately
as somebody who's foreign other skunks
in the uk mike
no we don't have administrators well the
tories but
ah nice hey
um no i've seen like four skunks and
they're very cute but every time
i just don't know what you're really
supposed to do about them keep it just
keep your distance yeah i had uh when i
lived in um the bay area uh the dog that
i lived with little pomeranian boy got
skunked and stank for like two full
weeks
wow it was so disgusting it's so strong
like you can smell if a skunk has gone
off probably a day beforehand if you're
just in the area it's oh it's white
jesus isn't that bad have you ever seen
in like cartoons and stuff no it's
terrible they're very cute and i think
they just like
rummage around and eat trash like
raccoons do but they like that smell is
no joke
i associate them growing up in colorado
every now and again one would end up as
roadkill
uh on like a highway and you would
essentially pass through the cloud
within like a day of its death and and
and and you'd pick up the smell
within you oh even when that dead it
smells i guess like i'm assuming that
like whatever killed it
you know it wasn't like sudden death i'm
assuming that it it sort of
traumatically did its little blast right
or they have a gland that when dead
could be all i know is like that it's
like it's like in dune
yeah
all i know is that i have many memories
as a kid where it literally it it's like
passing through a literal cloud where
you just you i just blew my mind that in
a car
you'd be like holy [ __ ] what is that um
yeah they're like never experienced this
it's like grassy but acidic at the same
time it's a very
distinct smell it's almost like if you
took weed
and made it just the nastiest thing
you've ever smelt
like okay because it is it is grassy
smelling in a weird way i've always
thought it smelled extremely similar to
wheat it does
yeah but was much much worse presumably
that's why it's called skunk
[ __ ] god
[Laughter]
yeah i've seen him when walking uh
canvas if we were walking around at like
daybreak you know occasionally we'll
take her out at like six in the morning
when it's when it's basically right at
sunrise
and more than once i've come across them
and she's always like hey what's that
and it's kind of like it's a standoff
you know look but don't touch yeah
exactly
uh because yeah they they they do act
super adorable but i've seen a i've seen
it like raise its tail kind of like a
scorpion where it's sort of like this is
the sign
i'm giving you i'm giving you all the
advanced notice
don't want that heat
yeah speaking of standoffs i have this
conversation with some friends recently
um i've never particularly liked
the traditional spaghetti western
and i think maybe i have not given one
enough of a chance that i need to sit
through it but they're so long
and then anytime that i see clips of
them my issue is that it's just a lot of
old men staring at each other while
music plays
just so much of men i'm just i'm i'm
trying to find the problem
i'm trying looking for your uh i was
like is it just this is like
massive masculine fantasy where you just
want to hold a gun and stare at another
man and that's why i'm like i don't why
would i want to watch this five minute
stare fest
first off if we're talking about leone
it's not just music
it is some of the greatest music
in the history of cinema i don't
disagree that would be a subset of music
though in fact still music actually
austin still musical but i'm saying it
is not merely music
inio marconi invented a genre and you
know he wrote that before they shot i
did know that he wrote the music and
then played it to them they would play
it back on set
um
also like those movies must been so hard
to make because people were speaking in
different languages
also every all of the dialogue was
recorded in post and so on the sets they
were just working
so people were building sets while they
were filming so it was the loudest set
in the world because they knew that they
weren't going to capture any of the
audio yeah so they were like just
building stuff in the background
production line wasn't it yeah proper
production line yeah to have men's skin
describing it as just men staring at
each other reminds me that
kerry describes
genre of movies i enjoy that she doesn't
as men in room talking
many rooms talking i love men in room
genre yeah i love men in room stores
movies but kerry's not my my favorite
movies are always just like like things
i love is is literally just people in a
room talking if they don't ever leave
the room even better
they'd stay in the same room the whole
time
four inch chest or like incredible like
a proper one room
even reservoir dogs is pretty close like
all of the the action in that is just
one room
saw counts i think saw is unironically a
very good film despite it being horror
and obviously like just appealing to the
score the first the first saw is a good
film
just the best my favorite episode of
breaking bad is the fly episode oh my
god beccal souls back
you've never watched it
oh you know how you like breaking bad
you're gonna no you're gonna yeah
they're gonna take saul and over five
years they're gonna make you
as invested in him as you were in
heisenberg i've only just in the last
like month
realized
that i've been a little bit asleep on
that one because i watched i think the
first season and into the second one and
i was just for some reason having a hard
time
no no breaking bad i was like i was
definitely one of those cultists
that was like you know
having a conversation with me is
predicated
on this show at this point
it's got less rocket fuel at the start
than breaking bad did because there's a
certain point especially for the first
season of bear call sorry like
why am i watching it's a bit it's a bit
like you know any prequel like it's just
like why am i i know where all these
characters are gonna end up i know
it just it doesn't and and chris
character you wouldn't be right
um
he's i think he's announced for the new
series i think that was a press release
they put out
but yeah the um
but it would be basically out of
necessity it would have to be
essentially cameo just given
yeah yeah
given like what you know
yeah most of the breaking bad cast has
shown up in at some point but you see
them at like earlier points in their
lives it's
it's so good and but yes for the first
season or two i definitely was watching
it going i'm watching this because i
liked breaking bad but i don't know what
i don't know why this story exists yeah
obviously just like breaking bad that's
me watching castle after firefly was
canceled uh i was like
this is not really satisfying my need
for more firefly but i apparently have
to watch this uh
uh and um
my favorite was when they were nathan
my favorite was there was an episode of
that show where they overtly made fun of
the demographic of me and presumably
lots of other where it's a halloween
episode where it starts off with him
in his malcolm reynolds costume and his
daughter says what is this outfit
supposed to be and he goes i'm a space
cowboy she goes didn't you wear this for
halloween like five years ago and he
goes yeah but it's a classic and she
goes i think it's time to let it go
[Laughter]
i was like i feel very attacked right
now uh why'd they have to call you out
like that yeah it was yeah yeah watch
back
for um
for as much for the other characters
than seoul to be honest
i mean look vince it's like skill again
earned my eternal loyalty with breaking
bad is basically the only show ever
that sustained equality and actually
managed to deliver on an ending
befitting the build-up i mean it's one
of the only
it's like it's you know it's one of
those that it is sort of a caricature to
hype that show at this point you are you
are silly but it is perfect i mean it is
it is one of those things where it
became
uh this ritual with my group of friends
to watch the new episodes each week
where you know it was like there were
like 10 of us that would just gather and
sit on the edge of our couch like
what the [ __ ] uh and just absolutely
became this staple of our life
i'm just really excited that you've
still got five more seasons of that to
watch that's gonna you're gonna have a
great time with it yeah the last time i
remember that being a phenomenon was
lost
where because it was also airing on tv
and everybody was talking about it at
the same time like
yeah that
at uni i remember we used to gather in
someone's dorm room and just watch like
each other until season two about three
episodes in where a lot of us started
everyone fell off it's just a little bit
difficult now because of streaming like
nobody's when you know you know watching
the same tv shows inherently like
they're just so many options well also i
also i was having a conversation with a
friend about this exact phenomenon uh
which i think could potentially also
relate to games in so far as the game
passed style
business models of
if retention
is if subscription retention is the goal
and
you you merely need to make sure people
hang on to that and there's no kind of
it's less about having a hit that makes
a gazillion dollars but
it lowers the bar therefore too i just
need games good enough to keep them from
unsubscribing
you end up with a
glut of potentially
fairly
uh you know potentially even reasonably
great but
but rarely like truly truly ambitious
and crazy because they just don't have
to now i could see the other argument
being the case that it actually buys
them the freedom to be more risky but
the friend of mine pointed out
since netflix
and and the others that followed disney
plus hulu blah blah blah
sort of ascended to the the throne
what has there been anything even
remotely approaching a kind of cultural
event
of a show and his argument was there's
only been one and it's not to the degree
and it's also like campy but in a way
that knows it is and so it's really not
the same which is stranger things that's
probably the biggest
like true like in terms of cultural
reach do you think that's what everyone
is talking about game of thrones do you
think that's about
game of thrones game of thrones predates
streaming
like i mean like the stream
i don't think that's i don't think
that's because those show i don't know i
don't think that's because shows now are
worse than they were it's just about
choice like alana said right like
there's a lot of tv now that's better
than lost
right but it's true i think the overall
like because average is higher yeah yeah
but no but look by your definition there
you're saying that the reason or sorry
my extrapolation of what you're saying
there is that the reason lost was a
phenomenon was because it was excellent
well it seems like which is i don't know
if that's true i think it was just the
one of four things you could watch and
therefore picked up an audience and i
think it was excellent at the time for
something airing on primetime tv it was
unlike anything a lot of people had ever
seen
considering how available it was whereas
sure
that show is also now there's more
competition of very good things yeah
you're not limited to a small pool of
things so therefore you're not and i
would argue to be honest that
i would say maybe some of the marvel tv
shows have achieved that right like i
think
i remember one division being a thing
that everyone was talking about i like
it
to an extent
like well yes you're right stranger
no but stranger things is
culturally
relevant renowned
in a way that one division is not we're
not still talking about one division
stranger things even though sure there's
a new season and i'm not watching
anymore because i think it got bad
stranger things is a thing that you but
it's also interesting because stranger
things still only exist because of
[ __ ] it
like
even that comes from a previous cultural
thing that we knew beforehand which is
80s kids on bikes
so it just extended the i mean it's
really crazy
name any and any work of art that's not
inspired by what are these kids on bikes
oh sorry
yeah i mean all the goodies
was notoriously inspired by 80s all of
them a lot of them
it's an interesting yeah i um
i
i think it's there are there sort of two
parallel lanes there of of
there are
one
to rule them all is less prevalent in a
world where there's just so much more
content and that overall
the average quality
is higher probably significantly higher
i mean the average show
on netflix is better than the average
show on abc 15 years ago
um i think it's probably safe to assume
i just watched this i'm not sure enough
that even though
i mean i would say
brilliant i'm saying average like yeah
always going to be a mix of of great and
mediocre and and generic and whatever
but like
if i pick something at random
um
it you know all
this could be another thing of
you know the way their their
you know
uh content curation per user works where
you know network tv obviously doesn't do
that you if i turn on nbc right now i'll
see whatever they're showing whereas if
i pick something at random it's not
actually random it's the things that
netflix has a hunch i will like
um
and so
the odds of me liking it go up the more
i watch netflix it's also temporarily is
your point that on but but temporarily
like abc 15 years ago
you're comparing the prime time slot if
we if we continued your randomization to
any time in 24 hours on that network you
randomly chose something obviously the
quality bar would slide down
significantly right
yeah well i that is what i meant
actually i was saying
like at any given time the quality is
likely to have been lower like yes there
is the occasional prime time prestige
kind of show
but
surrounded by lots of stuff that is
hardly that
um whereas the overall
aggregate appears to be higher as a side
note regarding lost
um
that show you know
to the end of the once we got into the
early 2000s
um basically all tv stopped recording
not all but almost all uh tvs stopped
recording their scores with live
musicians because computer
you know virtual instruments had kind of
reached a point that they real and also
just turn around times wow uh we're
were always sort of shrinking and
shrieking so whereas you have like star
trek next generation recording at stay
gym paramount with a 60 piece orchestra
every week and and still to this day the
simpsons recording with a live orchestra
um the that became increasingly
an extinct species and lost
and now it's made a little bit of a
comeback like all the disney plus and
marvel shows they all record you know
with pretty grand uh orchestras and then
like the high profile um stuff like
you know agents of shield and a lot of
like these are all using live
orchestra and they're still of course
the majority is probably still done uh
virtually or in a hybrid model but lost
was the one
with uh michael jacquino that was kind
of like his first really big credit in
his career it was his breakout right
that was basically technically alias
would have been because alias was also
jj abrams and led directly to lost but
um
but alias he got because jj abrams was a
gamer who played medal of honor
music in medal of honor wow um
and and and sort of brought him over
from there he has had the absolute
luckiest daisy chain
uh because he got he got you know
initially started in games doing
spielberg's the lost world and call of
duty and medal of honor in the late 90s
and then jj abrams played those hired
him for alias and lost and then brad
bird watched lost and called him to do
the incredibles wow
so it's just like this incredible insane
handoff of like some of the biggest name
talents but but um hit they recorded
at capital records with like
it was every single week was exactly the
same it was it was like 23 or so strings
four trombones piano and emil richards
at harp and email richards on percussion
for every episode of lost became kind of
like their palette and it was there were
no electronics it was 100 that orchestra
in that room
and that kind of started the hollywood
going you know i guess it's not that
expensive and it really does sound
better and i always so all the like
you know tv people uh tv composers oh a
a long-standing debt of gratitude to
jaquino for kind of
he and jj abrams and bad robot for kind
of saying no we actually we're willing
to spend the money on this we we think
this is
so it's worth it
come so i always
yeah i mean again it not every show can
afford it yeah but even like even
seemingly very straight ahead like i
have a friend who scores the cw remake
of uh
of uh kung fu the remake is it's so
different from the original kung fu that
i don't even know if remake counts
anymore it's just the the complete
reason
yeah it's like a totally different thing
from that i think i haven't i haven't
watched it but a friend of mine named
sherry chung writes the score for it and
i see her routinely recording with
strings she'll post on instagram like oh
you know season two episode three here's
a little glimpse of what we recorded for
that or whatever and like you know so
even a show like that which cw is
notoriously like how can we spend the
least amount possible um they're still
putting up some money for something uh
and and i think that that if it hadn't
been for lost validating that
uh you know maybe someone else would
have come along
made a big difference appreciate you
yeah i always associate you mentioned
simpsons austin i'm going to bring you
back you mentioned simpsons which made
me think danny elfman which i think the
audience needs to know your opinion of
buff elfman have you seen the picture
yeah him at coachella what
oh a lot oh you're about to go on the
journey
yeah just type in danny elfman coachella
i'd like to remind you while you type
that in he's 68 years old
he's older
i thought he was older is he only is he
68 okay
should i be looking at news losing his
shirt
there you go just do google images
the google image comes up with a lot of
different [ __ ] that is okay i'm just
gonna send you i don't know i'm gonna
send you the image oh wow i see
species oh wow
bro he hot what the hell
yeah he's he's always been what the [ __ ]
uh
he's always been one-of-a-kind have you
seen the comparisons there's like a
photo of him from like 20 years ago
where he looks older have you seen that
comparison
really i i haven't but i i don't doubt
it i mean he always had a kind of
he always had a kind of like
you know like igor quality he's always
kind of just been different
um
and uh so it makes him in a way ageless
but i think he's also really wow he's
conscientiously taking care of himself
he's totally ripped yeah
i wish i looked like that at 36.
it's like that 68. if you start now mike
you're in for a good shot um so speaking
of requests output
speaking of both netflix and things uh
putting money in certain places
i
the other night was like i will always
watch a horror movie it doesn't matter
what quality is i love horror and so i
put on this movie that it recommended to
me that's called choose or die or
otherwise it's called cursor
and the concept is not a unique one but
it's a video game that kills people they
play it the choices that they make in
the game
could impact real life um and they can't
call it choose your own adventure
because that's copyrighted and they're
very litigious it's also choose or die
and cursor fit into the film pretty well
there's another one called stay alive
where if you die in the game you die in
real life that uh anyway there are a
bunch of them but
um
did not think the film was particularly
good
uh but
it they had some really interesting
choices and one of them was clearly a
british cast who frequently messed up
their american accents and clearly shot
in england
but they tried to make it seem like new
york yes
see also the bubble yeah i kept trying
to look for the power outlets because
i'd be like they can't change the hotel
but the streets it was so clearly
english why did they not just
choose choose
choose or die
um but there are other things that were
really interesting to do with like when
you can see the filmmaking happening
that i wonder if a lot of audiences will
picture like there are very few sets in
this movie there's one part where they
take a road trip but the only footage
that you see of the road trip is this
one shipping dock and the rest of it
they put in video game and it was like
well clearly they only had the ability
to rent the shipping dock so they didn't
do the rest of the road trip because
they couldn't afford it and then there's
another part where
conflict that happens in what looks like
a
a room that's just full of like um
dry ice like it's just like uh
fake gas whatever and
fog yes that's what i'm looking for and
it's clearly just there
yeah everything eddie martin was a
surprising addition to the film um why
is he always in everything very good
like you can't he's in absolutely
everything isn't he oh i think that
usually implies a very um affordable day
rate yeah i would think that
like eric roberts is in ten thousand
movies yeah because he only had to shoot
bruce willis like bruce willis had
eight movies come out last year i think
because most of them were yeah a week
shooting at most for him isn't it for
him yeah a lot of body doubles he's done
now yeah yeah it's very sad yeah um but
yeah it was just clearly just creating a
nest egg you know totally it was just
very interesting to see this movie where
like there was a part where in theory
you would see
a monster in theory and i was like they
can't afford to show the monster there's
no way and so it doesn't happen
and it just doesn't really yeah there
was loads of stuff where it was like no
they i know that this movie doesn't have
the budget because of the amount of [ __ ]
that they've cut away from there's no
way that they can create a cgi monster
they didn't it's just a hole in a door
it's like
there you go
um fun watch but it's just a very
interesting thing to to
be able to so obviously see a budget and
and be able to guess what's happening in
the film because of the budget and they
did their best and were creative and
like i'm sure it was a very low budget
like i said the scene that's just fog in
a room was like
that's a great way to have a very
dramatic scene that is kind of spooky
but really all you did was make some
hallways and put some fog in a room like
all right like go for it but i i wonder
if most people will see that or if that
be like has become a part of my brain as
i've worked on a thing that costs money
more i don't know
uh if more more people will notice that
it doesn't have a great score across the
board it's so interesting how
uh
sort of video game concepts
uh
always come acro like any time you try
to make something sort of game-like
in a movie it's almost always just
agonizingly cheesy um and somehow the
only exception to that
is the amazing doug lyman
uh tom cruise
uh emily blunt movie um oh yeah it
looked i repeat as they call it now um
uh what was it called originally it's
edge of tomorrow tomorrow yeah or um
source code's great as well similar
similar i saw similar kind of game logic
roguelike movie yeah i saw northman last
night and that is amazing good i've
heard great things by that i really
enjoyed it i don't know that everybody
will i think it's probably going to be
pretty split i did really enjoy it
though but there are so many things in
it that are so video gamey
like a little
there's just like it oh i was i wanted
to talk to him so bad to be like do you
play video games this this is [ __ ]
questy as hell like get the sword at
this hour from this and then fight it
and like all right okay i see your
inspiration
but not
obviously a video game thing i would
agree that lived out you know that
raises an interesting question because
my my
my knee jerk reaction is to go
that narrative structure in games
is a
is rarely a writing
boon for that game it's seemingly always
a way to create content to lengthen a
game
it often feels that way to me like like
games that are more concise tend to work
better for for me where i'm at in my
life
and so anything that feels side quest
like i remember feeling that way
watching mandalorian where i thought
he's spending so much time
running errands
and not doing the thing that he's
supposedly doing because it's like well
i'll give you the sword but first i need
the dungeon key well i'll give you the
dungeon key but first i need the you
know the helm of and it's like
oh for the love of god that that's not
actually a compelling narrative
structure and it's one of you sorry no
no no go ahead i apologize i was gonna
say like do we think that's coming from
games or is that just coming from legend
like that's beowulf like go to a place
and find a thing that lets you get to
the next thing and find a place it's
true like that doesn't feel like the
odyssey
yeah if we only go back super far also
uh in my experience and obviously i
can't speak for everybody
the concept of this is in the game to
make the game longer doesn't really
exist
um
from the writers or from the narrative
design team it's always
like everything that i keep being told
because when i first started at sms i
kept like being like how long would this
bit be and they'd be like don't worry
about it and i just couldn't get it out
of my head that i was like but i need to
know for this how long is it as a scene
they were like yeah don't worry about it
i keep being told so how sorry how long
is the new god of war just so for the
for the
don't worry about it
everything uh will end up being three
times longer than you planned for um
that is what i keep being told video
games will always end up being three
times longer than you planned for and
that you should expect them to be too
long and to require cuts and i i would
not have thought that before working
on a design team um and i wonder if
that's industry-wide that i don't know
the consensus of we need to do this to
make this longer actually exists i've
seen it i've seen it on multiple games
i've worked on uh people have said that
to you
well obviously i'm in no uh not to me as
if as if i somehow could make it longer
but i have i have asked questions before
about
xyz content and they're like
we are basically under pressure from the
publisher to
uh
it
well
it depends on how you define indie
someone who is beholden to a publisher
one way or the other is the reason why
this comes up so in the strictest sense
of indie uh this this wouldn't come up
but i've seen it on games where and i
mean i remember this was a this was a
concern during journey when journey was
clocking in at like 80 minutes and they
were going
they were you know remembering that this
was 2012 and it was a very different
market than today they were going what
game could we possibly compare this with
players are going to think that this is
a rip off no matter what we charge it
was a huge issue with the order
obviously like people were very upset
about the length of that game
so it is woefully unfair me too i like
that game a lot plus go play it today i
wish there'd been a sequel it looks like
it just came out that game has held up
visually unbelievably i liked it a lot
it deserved to see it i wonder if
it's
again the studio i would agree with you
it's has a very specific structure in
that like it is a very story-first
studio and that is not necessarily that
common
in aaa i was just talking at gdc to
somebody who works uh for well maybe i
shouldn't say another aaa studio
and
they were asking me about that because
they'd heard that about santa monica
studio and they were like man that must
be so nice as a writer
because a lot of other studios things
function in a way that's like you get a
level and then they're like and then and
then you ride it it's like a very
different direction which i do worry
about
oh i for sure don't worry
there are very few aaa studios that i
would work for that's why though like i
say like it would only be sms or
rockstar
and that's why
which like i'm aware is like maybe an
indie studio would be fine but otherwise
it's those two in tripoli no i'd say i'd
say we have we have equal if not
potentially more pressure than what
austin's describing because yeah in most
cases you're beholden
we're lucky i think just not a thing
that is in my
department at all that writers are but
they probably are i don't know because
again i'm and this isn't just the studio
i work for it is conversations i've had
with other people that have been like no
no the game was way longer than we hoped
i always hear that so i'm wondering
if it's only when something's on the
extremely short side that the publisher
goes it needs to be longer it's risk no
it's 100 that's risky i think it also no
one's saying this game needs to be this
game the 20 hours needs to be 30 hours
it's entirely about
avoiding the danger so with your game
um and your studio there's an
understanding and an acknowledgement and
just in it's just an awareness of what a
game from your studio is they'd have an
assumption of like and also it's like
600 people like you're not gonna yeah
you have to all those people have to
have work to do like you can't just make
it before he walks into a room if yeah
if cory if corey goes over to herman's
like the next game's gonna be three
hours long then yeah the matter of time
is going to come up as an issue but it's
understood yeah that's true i think on
the indie side it's similar to an extent
again like people like known quantities
so we as a studio don't ever get asked
about game length by partners because
our games are well we we they've we've
never had a review that said this game
was too short so therefore no one
worries about us for too long probably
too long what are you using oh yeah
we're five-ish we're quite concerned
in terms of hours
wick was probably the longest that's
probably about six or seven that makes
sense
but yeah no exactly um it's and that's
and that's been generally fine what i
would say i worry about more as a writer
is um relative timing so while i won't
add stuff to a game just to inflate the
full running time there is one hundred
percent like a pacing choice i'm sure
you've made some other choices where
like you're like this is this bit
because it doesn't feel right this bit
is too short or not long enough
the player needs a bit of space to think
about the thing that just happened we
have to have some content here for them
to churn through while that's whirring
in the back of their head that but
that's croft that's that's pacing that's
that that's something that's essential
but as you say it's also
you can do your best to achieve it but
also you never know which bits of player
is going to get stuck on how long
something's going to end up taking we
tend to work towards
like a minimum
time so from uh from uh
you know we need to from a risk
mitigation point of view where like this
game has to be at least this long so
we'll make sure that you you know a
relative speed run without using any
exploits will take
x amount of time and our average player
we want it to take about this long and
we'll kind of bear that in mind as we go
but beyond that no and we're we're not
we're not fast the um but i i think when
genre games
franchises how like austin was this a
prevalent thing that you had heard
studios say that it needed to be you've
probably worked on many more games than
us combined that's true and it's one of
the that is one of the uh perks of
of this one it's all over the place
i do get to i get a good sampling of
different types of teams different types
of genres of games you know different
publisher developer relationships all
that kind of stuff i feel very lucky to
have a really eclectic
uh sort of
experience set to draw from so far i
wouldn't say it's been that way on even
a majority of games but it's definitely
been a it does exist noticeable thing
and i think i think the crucial aspect
that you kind of tapped on the edges of
mike when you said a studio like sms is
sort of a known quantity
i think that the genre of the game is
also a giant part of of
length
yeah like
uh because i i i there was one that i
worked on
where
as they were you know moving towards
you know the they could see the light at
the end of the tunnel
uh and the game was was not finished
there was still plenty of room for
things to change and evolve and whatnot
as they kind of took stock on what the
trajectory was looking like they
realized they were going to come in
with less overall
content
than
comparable titles in that space
and that was a big concern for the
publisher because it was like
players will come to this
with a certain amount of expectation
you yeah i i should be able to do this
or or that at minimum yeah and if if i'm
below that minimum or at least even if
i'm not but there's just the perception
that i'm below that minimum
uh that that can that can kill us
and i remember that being an interesting
time
yeah it was interesting it was but it
was very contextual to the kind of game
you know because like we're still
talking about a game that's far longer
than
you know journey and especially once
journey kind of
once people played it and realized oh
yeah this shouldn't be longer like this
this shouldn't this this
you know this really is the gandalf like
it took his lag exactly as long as it
needed kind of model
um and they were merciless that game
company about cutting everything that
added fluff like the game was meant to
be a hundred percent sort of
trimmed
of all fat and superfluous content um
such that you couldn't cut anything else
but everything was essential
um and that was sort of
i think
what what drove that and the fact that
that was unusual at the time
definitely required placating some some
sony nerves i believe uh at the time it
helped that journey was overall not that
expensive to make but it was that's the
weirdest part of this is that strangely
i'd say
journey
and
sony's internal games in general
um
are similar to and this is true of any
platform holder like simultaneously
probably
the higher ups are having to have lots
of conversations about this stuff but at
the same time
are supported in the marketplace so
strongly that i think you can overcome
so if so you know if a game if
uh
let's let's move away from let's say the
next gears of war there you go if the
next gears of war game i'm just going to
help you out a lot
yeah let's say the next gears of war
game is like half the duration of any
previous gears of war game
there are
a lot of people
in microsoft and in their marketing
departments who can frame that and
position that for the audience and can
kind of explain that to the audience and
make that something that's kind of known
and comfortable with in a way that if a
a double a studio or even like an uh you
know a triple a studio like ubisoft or
ea
probably doesn't have the same level of
resource to do that or and won't so
they're more likely to pressure the
developers just add some filler you know
potentially
with something like journey you know
yeah you you got to cut all that fat but
like journey wasn't competing in the
marketplace
um
like another indie
studio like they were they had this this
this uh red carpet rolled out for them
and that allowed them probably a bit
more creative freedom and control and a
bit less fear of the audience backlash
than uh an indie developer who didn't
have that level of support
it's good you should take advantage when
you have that situation i'm not knocking
them for it but like there's definitely
like a different amount of politics
involved there right yeah related to
that i wonder
if it's prevalent in aaa again me saying
i don't think this exists comes from me
realizing it didn't in my experience but
then also talking to other people other
writers in triple a and them all saying
the same thing so i wonder if it's also
they're not in the room potentially
that's true
they're not in the room where those
conversations are happening yeah
yeah
like i said
i expected it to be part of my journey
the director of gears of war yeah the
director of gears of war there you go
who is that he's not he's he's not rod
ferguson um diablo i don't even know who
the director of gears is right now
um no i think um yeah they're having
that conversation like yeah you're
probably right frankly like part of your
job leading a games company is is is
having to deal with difficult
conversations that that the team doesn't
necessarily need to hear at indie scale
and at small scale i'm much more
transparent with my team because that
makes sense but like at a big company i
imagine there's a lot of drama that
you're probably very glad that your
bosses are not telling you about that
yeah it's their job to protect the
creatives i think in a lot of cases so
that's entirely true yeah it makes me uh
it makes me think of something i never
actually thought about before
the mass effect franchise
being
um
not
especially the first game
i never thought of those as like really
mainstream kind of games because they're
fairly in the weeds
rpgs
which is not a that's not the same thing
fundamentally as a halo or a zelda or
something which is i think just casts a
far wider net right
and so mass effect always had this
interesting challenge of as the budget
by the time they got to mass effect 3
was clearly like they they had become
such a critical darling and had such a
loyal following that they
they clearly took a bit of a
gamble on the third one to be a pretty
high budget high prestige title but
there's only so far you can really go
with that because there's just only so
many sales a game like that is likely to
yield and it makes me wonder i never
thought about
before one of the kind of controversial
decisions at the time
was the
inclusion of multiplayer in mass effect
3 which directly impacted your story
potential basically if you didn't yeah
they've mitigated this subsequently with
the with patches and then of course in
the legendary edition but originally at
launch
um
you couldn't
um
achieve the most uh sort of like the the
most ideal outcome
without
logging time playing multiple well
that's a terrible idea
um it was a way to
i did like that multiplayer but that's a
terrible idea i actually really liked it
from the standpoint i wish they could
have they could have done like a
skirmish mode that had the same effect
but what i liked about it from a purely
immersive storytelling standpoint
was that
the storyline is telling us there is a
giant war
like
a war on a level that you can't even
comprehend across like thousands of
planets involving everyone in the galaxy
happening right now
and you being the hero and the leader of
the military you're kind of only
existing at the high level
decision making you you know la you
don't really taste the boots on the
ground reality of the war but the
multiplayer gave you this
feeling of
uh you know they're like oh we need to
evacuate this city just go help some
civilians out because there's an
invasion and we're just trying to pull
them out and it made it it made it feel
like approach yeah it made it feel like
you need to dip your toes periodically
in in the reality of of this larger
conflict that's not if i win this battle
all i get out of it is i save a few
people's lives i don't like win the war
and defeat the boss and it's way more
narrow in in scope and i felt like as a
as a counterpoint especially just a
whenever you feel like doing it not not
driven by narrative but just oh i want
to play some multiplayer it somehow
added to the overall feeling now part of
it is that i have very rose-colored
glasses and i just love everything about
mass effect and the particular mass
effect
no i could i could i as my as my
shepherd helmet is
highest selling game ever
mass effect really sold seven more than
dragon age dragon age inquisition was
six million
wow had guns in it had guns in it seven
million yeah um uh that's interesting
well i i mean
all of which is to say it makes me
wonder if part of the calculation on the
budget was a multiplayer mode will
be an investment in the game's ecosystem
that's separate from just
the core
we've been spooling up this big grand
epic story and we're bringing it home
and people want to see how it ends but
there's actually there's even just a
foundational gameplay reason for people
to join
i never thought of it as like
you know a kind of potentially quasi
hedge betting
uh
move to to and i've never heard that
you know spoken to i have no idea if
that was a thing because it was
definitely a bit controversial and they
made it way more optional
three was also the first one that
required you to download origin to play
it on pc if i remember correctly mm-hmm
and that was that was that was
that one that was my that was my just
like the orange box that was my uh
i remember the orange box was what
forced me to download steam
uh and uh this was uh this was the fifth
thing i started to
i think download sorry go ahead
now you're absolutely you're right i'm
saying austin's absolutely right i think
the um
the other thing is of course uh the the
emphasis and the investment in third
person action in the second mass effect
game like there's definitely it was of
that era where that was because the
reality is if you've not if you've got
any kind of media property that's not
just saturated to the extent that
everyone's experienced it already which
mass effect obviously never hit that
level the
these stats are really interesting and i
think what like this whole conversation
is interesting in general is like is
mass effect mainstream to us it feels
like it is but
probably not really the average gamer
has not played the first mass effect so
i mean that era games weren't mainstream
that's true
the first mass effect
two million
yeah that is you're
probably one of their worst selling
games
if your sales pitch for the third game
was exclusively
finished the story you started
then by definition there's a cap on that
audience to what however me number two
sold like because that's if that's the
only reason in the same way as if better
call saul was marketed as
you know find out about what happened
you know the triggered breaking bad
finally the story you've been looking
for if that was the only pitch then
they're capped to break that that
approach works if you're promoting
avengers infinity war because everyone
has experienced that stuff so you know
hey our audience for infinity war is a
subset of everyone in the world cool
whereas i actually think that one went
the other way i think like i think
you're right but i think they luck i
think they just they inherited well they
they built something that
that uh
managed to
go
it like reversed the polarity you know
where there were people seeing infinity
war who had been completely checked out
of the mcu because the hype reached such
a fever pitch that they're like okay
fine i'll go see this one i may as well
see how it all yeah i haven't bothered
the 20 prior
i've heard it's actually there's a
youtuber i like called on patrick
williams who did a video where his his
parents saw it and the i think the only
marvel movie they'd seen was iron man
and he took them to he was end game
specifically the second one and he they
want they just told him one day i'm
similar to what austin said of like they
just they felt like they had to watch it
so they asked him if he could take them
and he recorded like basically a
40-minute interview with them after and
they got it like it's a testament to how
good the storytelling and the writing is
in those movies i will [ __ ] on those
movies for plenty they explain the whole
story i think the fact that end game
came together
it was viewable by everyone and legible
but then
also threaded 20 movies over a decade
with like the exact traces of where the
tesseract was and when for all the
people who got hardcore and made sense
is incredible it's good character pain
too
amazing
like genuinely alana i've i on
ironically recommend the audio
commentaries for infinity war and end
game like basically the six hours that
that's uh it's up to it's the it's the
directors and i think one of the writers
and they basically don't talk about
anything except what you're talking
about the story stuff it's so impressive
it's and but listening to them talk
about like like i genuinely like i've
recommended that to like young writers
of like go and spend six hours oh but
it's it's just a marvel movie it's like
no go and spend six hours and listen to
the thought process behind every i love
the dismissive idea like this thing that
a billion people got excited about oh
it's just one of those yeah but i mean
i'm creating that's right austin
okay as a young creative they have a
formula that i don't like
and got very bored of
um and and the humor and the structure
and the arcs like there are a lot of
things that are very samey about them in
a way that like i don't disagree with
the popcorn criticism even though i went
and saw them all but like if you were to
dismiss all of that like well it's
disney
they have all this money of course they
can make this happen no that almost
makes it harder the fact that it's owned
by disney they have all the money in the
world and they didn't have executives
being like no no no no and look at star
wars on a parallel track totally look at
star wars on a parallel track i don't
even know what happened in that last
[ __ ] movie i still don't know what
happened we have to stop talking about
stalls
but
it's just very impressive that it all
managed to come together
i i don't know if anyone will ever be
able to do it again like it's amazing
it does feel like it does feel like they
are they are flapping in the wind right
now and a bit like the spider-man film
was was was really fun
and in a great uh great it was amazingly
written though as well
beautiful yeah i i i i
i
but
really on on what uh i think we might
have spoken about this before that i
didn't buy no we have to help the mass
murderers as a motive i was like this is
illogical and ridiculous you're risking
the fabrics of reality this doesn't make
any [ __ ] sense nobody would do this
i did find it i did find um i did find
uh doctor strange
oddly easily persuadable to do a
world-altering spelling that would
destroy absolutely everything no none of
you would have done any of this no
it was always a good voice of reason so
it was a little it was a little bit like
no no we we need this movie and his
movie to happen so
just roll with it uh yeah and it was
like well okay
again i had a moment where i was like i
just need to let that go it's fine it's
a comic book movie and then i let it go
and it was great it was very emotional
had a good time i love the screen rant
uh pitch meeting
uh observation about that movie where
they talk about like we need to send
them home uh we need to send these
villains home back to like you know kind
of face their destiny in their in their
original timeline except the movie
earlier establishes that they all were
like warped out at the exact point of
death so you're like we got to send them
back we got to send to the exact moment
of their death that's like our big
that's our big achievements uh which i
was like yeah you're right they don't
actually address that i don't logic
problems some logic problems but again
it's fine um it's actually not a logic
problem it's like a because it
there's nothing i don't think there's
anything
logic breaking about that it's just sort
of like
it's like they forgot if they forgot
the premise of their own it's crucial
business isn't it it's it's it's a ghost
story it's the idea of them making
amends before their last moment that's
how i read it
that's a very
charitable finding peace in their last
moment hmm
that's that was my read anyway i did not
take it no definitely like anyone
watching this who wants to write like
genre stuff definitely go speaking wait
wait pause
what the [ __ ] is up with the hoodie
thing uh
you don't remember you were there so we
got a bunch of comments on a recent
episode about how he's like
no you were
at one point during the episode
we were saying a bunch of [ __ ] about
religion that we knew everyone would be
mad about and so mike said give us a
compliment tell austin how nice his
hoodie is or something along those lines
past me no you responded you were saying
something particularly sacrificial we
just don't remember what we say
um that's true another interesting
bioware sales fact for you
okay good ball is gay
the projections for the commercial
performance at baldur's gate were very
low which makes sense by the way
expected to have worldwide sales of 200
000 which would be enough for them to
justify a sequel
um what what year
2000 it was 2003 i think
baldur's gate wasn't earlier no that
would have to be earlier than that
that's the latest sales well you did
boulder skate come out has to be earlier
that's much earlier
both because i love i love those humble
like 90s like if we see 79 000 copies it
was the best you know it was our best
year ever
we have 2003 was when we had worldwide
sales of 2.2 million and they had they
had hoped to just get a measly 200 000
isn't that they had an order of
magnitude more than they were expecting
wild anthem still sold five million mass
effect andromeda five million mass
effect two five million dragon age
inquisition six anthem do five million
that's actually genuinely impressive
given
a game that's considered like
essentially a failure or at least
disappointing yeah yeah
that kind of thing is always
is always those those different
perspectives uh of
and and the kind of
by way of analogy this sort of like
overton window of sales moving of what
constitutes a a hit versus a failure
um
is so endlessly
uh interesting to me and you be changing
and and
and to that end you know the fact that
such small teams can also make such
great games like the with the way like
we talk obviously about inscription a
lot or obviously
yeah yeah another great example of your
eyes um
lovely by the way i met them for the
first time they are lovely aren't they
yes
they oh yeah the unpacking folks are
lovely and so are the before your eyes
folks
um inscription folks all so good they're
all i've heard them i've not met them
but i've heard they're great yes all
wonderful jerks
every day you make something that's
[ __ ] brilliant
and when you think about it my
generation of indie devs all turned out
to be monsters
just give them time this group is still
fermenting
i'm still upset about this somebody in
the comments was like just really want
to give austin a shout out for
recommending that i play inscription
yeah that you play
i mean look let's just face facts that's
he played it because
no no no that that that commenter is the
only one that has a real window into
reality oh infuriating
i love it when the commenters give me a
quote from you and say i really like
dwight's point about that that was great
i i also really have no way telling of
larger problems
warhammer and often gets like oh cool
you're into warhammer because of me
but nobody ever gets like you should try
to get a lot into it
did he get alermo del taro into it
that's my question it's a good question
because i've seen them interact on
twitter and the lemon del toro is now
doing the models
and that's to have any influence on him
is a lot easier i will take credit for
that also because the person who got
rahul i think so yeah that's uh
i will take it you're you're two layers
above in the pyramid thank you i
appreciate that i look forward to a
month from now when i'm credited with
getting rolling warhammer 100
if everyone in the comments could just
congratulate austin on getting raffle
into yes this time i'm gonna remember
i'm gonna do my best to remember this
moment um i'm actually gonna enjoy the
show right now hi everybody welcome to
play watch listen this is episode 99
look at us go i'm a lot of peace i'm a
video game right at that is mike bithell
he's a video game director that is
austin wintry he's a video game composer
troy still busy i think troy yeah he
actually i actually texted him to say
are you gonna be able to join us and he
was like i'm i'm hoping we rap in time
and sent me a little fingers crossed
emoji and okay i'm guessing that means
they didn't um so we're still trying to
figure out what we want to do for
episode 100 so i'm going to recommend
that people follow at pwl underscore
podcast on twitter and that is where i
will post the updates um we're planning
to try to do
a live stream episode uh but have to
figure out the timing for that because
schedules are a nightmare second thing i
wanted to say um
austin obviously just got back from a
trip where he's grown a beard um really
it's how you can tell he's been living
his best life but i really wanted to ask
you about monkey island
it's been that long since we oh yeah i i
uh it made me excited to see that there
that they're doing it i think it's
um
it raises an eyebrow for tim to not be
involved yeah um i i know obviously he's
mostly just busy with his own company uh
so i don't you know put
too much thought into that but i just
think of him as so central to cool if he
could like consult or something but yeah
he's got a whole lot double fine to run
yeah and i but i did i i did it always
warms my heart when i see
uh the like the press release
essentially it's like sentence three
where they said including the return of
clinton jake and peter mcconnell and
michael land uh the original three
composers who were the
they were the trio who did they were
basically the audio department of
lucasarts in the late 80s through the
90s where each person you know michael
land famously did the music on monkey
island and they would all kind of help
on sound design and audio implementation
and programming uh peter of course did
the music for graham fandango uh clint
did the music for outlaws
uh and they all
you know like i i seem to remember once
i think it was clint told me he recorded
a harley in the lobby at ilm for sound
designing on full throttle like
literally like making the glass like
flex as it just roars this unbelievably
loud engine just in the lobby
uh something like that i think it was
clint who told me that
um so yeah anyway those three guys are
like three of my
heroes i've never actually i met michael
once but clint and peter are both good
friends and it's one of those things of
i consider it an incredible privilege of
my career trajectory that i can call
someone
who were genuinely childhood heroes of
mine um as just
friends that i that i that i you know
could call at any moment and it was rant
popcorn thing
jesus
uh
and uh but uh
uh i refused to dignify uh
never heard of him
um but no yeah i so anyway i i liked
that
it made me happy that they they made a
point of saying that i thought their
little teaser was evocative the only way
that it's like it's so
it feels like it's rare that you see
something like that actually get remade
from the the same people largely
obviously except for tim
um
and that they got to do it on the
creator had made a joke about if he were
ever to make another monkey island he
tweeted on april 1st and that's exactly
how they announced it
like the fact that that all came
together i don't know it's just like so
there was one thing that struck me as
curious was that ron gilbert said
it would i don't think it's a remake
it's essentially a sequel
to monkey island 2
which i thought was interesting because
it made it sound like we pretend none of
the others happen now i understand the
the kind of awkwardness regarding the
telltale games but monkey island 3 was
awesome you can't and like to me curse
of monkey island was kind of like
you know you're wrong i can and
that's that's monkey island legends now
that's monkey curse of monkey island
he's joking
no it's no it's it's it's i get that i i
get the slight clean except one and two
i think i think they're carrying but
that doesn't make anybody does that make
sense to me because lucasarts like it
was it was the three games now i'm
worried i've heard a rumor and i'm going
to just quickly double check i could
sort of
non-canonical just sort of
they're their own thing
but
i thought the third one i thought the
core actual lucas arts titles were a
few truly returned to monkey island uh
will be a direct continuation of monkey
island to a direct sequel to monkey
island too they yeah no i don't no no i
definitely you're right i heard that
that's that's what i'm but i'm just i
find that
i find that peculiar because the third
one was excellent um
and uh at least i remember it being
excellent and it felt very much like a
sequel to the second which was a great
sequel to the first like to me those
three are an excellent
trilogy of games and i i and that's why
i forgive them going yeah the
the legends or whatever that followed
the kind of episodic telltale thing with
like that never happened
but it was odd to s
to me i mean there's clearly something i
don't know
that would provoke sweeping the third
one under the rug i always look if
nothing else
the insult sword fighting
wherein you have to rhyme with your
opponent which was the wrinkle they
added since the third one was the first
one that was voiced
and
the whole premise is we're not just
sword fighting but now we're
swashbuckling on the decks of pirate
ships and they go the rule on the open
sea
is that the
the insults have to rhyme
uh
and i was as a kid it
it was so uh delightful to me to be the
way they tutorialized that is they they
get you in a sea shanty that it's an
endless loop that you can't get out of
it everything you say they'll rhyme with
and until eventually
one of the dialogue options that starts
to filter into the choices is to end
with the word orange
which is what grinds the whole thing to
a halt and gets you actually out of the
eternal loop and i always remember like
that just it's just one of those very
memorable little
for anyone who hasn't gameplay again
monkey island probably not that popular
in the grand scheme of things um are
they playable like you play them just
it's a great yeah there's a there you go
yeah it was an awesome special edition
version recently oh dude the the the the
remastered monkey island flick between
the two yeah
not just that they the original score
was all
you know midi at predated
on steam it predated cd-rom you know
like the original the original uh was
all of course electronic
and
when they did the the remastered uh
edition
uh my friend jesse harlan who was who
was the kind of in-house music director
at lucasarts at the time
working with some other some other folks
had to reconstruct the original score
down to the note so that when you hit
f11 or whatever would talk would flip
back and forth the music would
cross-fade right on the beat
to the old version of the music as well
uh like throughout the game so the the
fact that halo does not put that
oh
because it's all the new ones all live
instruments and sounds amazing they
produced it so beautifully
like through again i would like to as
well and they're not that long it's
funny the monkey island collection on
steam
is currently 25 46 and i might buy it
but it says more like this and recommend
it as fable anniversary that makes sense
to me that those would be in the same
category spyro reignited trilogy also
makes sense and then papers please
papers please is uh is so it comes up on
everything
notoriously just very um uplifting like
cartoony funny no it's a maths thing
it's because so
the way those the way those
recommendations work is it's things that
have been clicked on most by users when
visiting do you think everybody just
clicks on pages please
it's because papers please has been on
there so long so thomas was alone often
shows up in those for like the weirdest
games as well it was really simple
that was like an early steam
uh early in terms of if you look at the
ramp up of content on steam yeah we were
ahead of that curve before before like
everything back when steam was releasing
like when thomas came out i think thomas
was alone was the only game released on
steam for a week
wow similar papers please like we were
so early that everything clicked through
which means there's all this historic
data that's driving those stories so
yeah you'll see thomas was alone pop-up
under like
ridiculously
weird um
just just go back in time and put them
on steam in 2013 and you'll be fine it's
my that's my key advice to any indie
developer right now is starter
papers please
i don't know why it won't pop up now
i was looking at the amount of reviews
so like spyro has seven thousand
for some reason papers please is now
just not popping up but it was at like
forty thousand crash bandicoot and same
trilogy is nine
i guess i guess you're right it's just
been played on steam so much
that it has it's just so brilliant it's
weird if you have older games
with older games than papers please that
number
nose dives because so like older games
because
steam didn't always have reviews so if
you go way back
there's games that you think would have
way more reviews that came out before it
that have very few because there didn't
used to be reviews on steam
so like the review numbers on a lot of
like
big hit games that you would think would
be massive actually very small numbers
people forget that like these platforms
have been around long enough now that
like there's legacy and there's like the
history of different games on there like
yeah if you go back and look at like
indie games from like two thousand like
what does uh like probably literally
like half-life
how many reviews
yeah i mean considering that so
half-life is why steam exists
essentially
so super meat boy for example 22 000
reviews that was a very popular game
but you'd think it would happen
that's my point is it kind of nosedives
as you go back it's fascinating like
half-life probably fifty-eight boy
probably has more sales than papers
please everything overall is that okay
no this is that's what i'm saying yeah
so but it should have so it should have
more reviews but it doesn't because it
came out before too early that's so
weird um came out what's horrible
it says
58 000 in overwhelmingly positive or no
no no no sorry it's saying overall
reviews overwhelmed me positive 58 000.
so i think that is saying it has 58 000
reviews papers please doing damn well
very good game if you haven't played it
it's really good
cheers lucas pope yeah
um i love it when we get into
data look at us go
oh darling i used to have to live in
steam data i now have other people who
worry about steam data i don't know
who's done h is thinking about that [ __ ]
yeah
uh what can people wish right
professionals somebody left a comment on
the episode when you told people to
wishlist um
solitaire conspiracy and they were like
i finally did it mike i finally put it
on my wish list it was like you think
you're making a joke but it still helps
yeah solitaire conspiracy people should
just go and wishlist solitaire
conspiracy or better yet like definitely
buy it if you want that'd be sick wish
list it then buy it do both don't do
both
both do both leave a good review as well
yeah 58 000 of them please yeah
steam is more than most platforms steams
steam is just so like algorithmically
driven that there are like the more you
interact with games on steam the more
you click on things and do things around
them and leave comments go on the forum
same as youtube really helps developers
like comment and subscribe everybody
thanks for watching play watch listen
and ring that bell
uh i don't even know what the bell does
it gives people notifications i've never
said it before but they they go ring
ring the bell
ring ring the bell um it's so strange i
i don't understand the point of having
that differentiation what like why would
you subscribe to your channel you don't
want to
know when they publish content i think
it's because people subscribe to
subscribe and then the ones that you'll
subscribe to as someone who very rarely
uses youtube
they would show up
like in more of a feed whereas if you
ring the bell it'll come up as like a
pop-up notification like you've received
a message
i think
i could be wrong but i get pop-up
notifications for youtube videos for
things i don't subscribe to really based
as recommendations
yeah but it won't it shouldn't come up
in your notification center it does huh
i don't [ __ ] i'm sure i can disable
that but half the time you're like
bringing bells in your sleeves yeah he
just he can't stop notifying he can't
stop bringing bells
can't help himself that's so true
um all right we will leave it there
everybody but
yes um stay tuned to at pwl underscore
podcast for
whenever we figure out what we're doing
for episode 100 i just want to make sure
we have troy
and in theory that may require us
delaying a week hopefully not i don't
know but we'll make it happen thank you
for 99 episodes we will see you next
time
[Music]